ROMAN NURIK: Hello and welcome,
once again, to
Android Design in Action.
I'm your host, Roman Nurik.
NICK BUTCHER: And hi, my
name is Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: And today we have
a special episode where we're
going to talk about--
actually, we're going to dive
into one of the apps that was
previously covered in the
GDG App Clinic Oslo.
In Norway, for those
of you that aren't
very good with geography.
And then we're going to dive
into some details on design
consistency, specifically
talking about when you should
think about your brand versus
Holo and Android design
principles and when
those meet.
So with that.
Let's get started.
So we're going to be talking
about one app today.
I'm probably not going
to pronounce it
right, but it's Finn.no.
It's kind of like a market-type
app, almost like
an eBay, I'd say.
And, again, everything was in
Norwegian, so I wasn't able to
fully grasp the full
extent of the app.
But it is like a market-type
app that lets you look at
products, find products.
It's got a very deep
hierarchy.
It's got a very deep hierarchy,
so there are lots
of different parts of the app,
which we'll talk about.
But yeah, let's just dive in.
So here's one of the
first screens that
you'll see in the app.
You'll notice that it's kind
of like an intro screen.
It's very nice that it kind of
introduces you to the main
character, the main, I guess,
spokesperson for this company,
this kind of cute
cat character.
And then you immediately jump
into content, which is nice.
There's no heavy introduction
screen.
There's no dashboard pad.
You immediately get content.
And this primary content area
is all about posts that this
company releases, I believe.
And then for each post
there's listings
associated with those.
So you'll see here that there's
this one post that
talks about something that's
on the market right now.
I believe it's a property
for sale, or for rent.
And then there's another about
wedding dresses or
something like that.
So there's a couple of other
details in the app which we'll
talk about throughout.
But we also wanted to talk about
some of the things that
we decided to change, some of
the things that we've decided
to tweak around with.
So the first is, you'll
notice that there's
this kind of top bar.
It's not really an action bar.
It has the logo in the middle,
whereas the action bar usually
has the logo on the left.
And it has affordances
for Search.
Search as well as filter.
And then Login, which
is in the right.
There's also a couple other
things you'll see here.
For each one of these posts,
you can actually click this
button here to take you to all
the listings related to that
post, versus if there's
only one item, you'll
just see one here.
There's no arrow there.
So we found that a little bit
confusing that there were two
different states, two different
places that this
touch area could lead you to.
Either just the single listing
or the full set of listings.
OK, so let's see what
we did with this.
Actually, before we
do that, Nick, do
you have any thoughts?
Anything to share?
NICK BUTCHER: No, overall it's a
quite clean and flat design,
which is very modern
and nice looking.
But there's just a few things
which kind of didn't quite sit
right for me and the
Android pattern.
So let's see what we've
done with this screen.
ROMAN NURIK: So the first thing
we did was we added a
proper action bar.
Actually, I'll just
zoom in here.
We added a proper action bar.
We also added a navigation
drawer, which we'll talk about
in just a second.
But we also tweaked a
lot of the metrics.
And that's one of the things
that I definitely tend to harp
on when I look at
apps is metrics.
Spacing, font sizes, margins,
paddings, things like that.
You'll notice that in the
original, the text, I guess
the titles are kind of cramped
with the image to the left.
And then the font sizes
vary throughout.
So one of the things that we did
was we standardized some
of the font sizes as well
as some of the margins.
We used a standard
16 dip base grid.
We have 16 dip margins
throughout.
We use 8 dip in some places.
But you'll notice that's just a
little more properly spaced
out, in my opinion.
We also obviously did some
tweaks here in terms of rather
than using these card-style
boxes to hold a single post
with its associated listings,
we kind of used this, almost
like a section header styling,
where you have a grey
background for the post itself,
the text of the post,
or the comment, I guess.
And then each of the items,
which is really the thing you
want to pop the most, has a
slightly different styling, a
lighter background.
We also, in the action bar, we
moved search into its proper
position at the top right.
We left the overflow for things
like my profile, which
is something that was given a
lot of prominence here, but we
decided to relegate it to the
overflow, since that's kind of
a very common place to put it.
And then we added the navigation
drawer, which we'll
show in a second.
Before we move on to the next
screen, Nick, any comments?
NICK BUTCHER: I was going to
say, I'm a particularly big
fan of the typography.
I find screens which have a
large range of different type
sizes on them, can
feel messy to me.
It's almost like people trying
to hard the communicate the
information hierarchy, and it
ends up just getting a little
bit confused.
I think you've done a really
nice job here of cleaning up
the typographic palette here.
So using typographic fewer type
sizes, but using font,
weight, and color, instead, to
communicate what is important.
And what is and less important
right now.
So I think that's a
really nice job.
Also we like the profile photos
with the dotted lines.
I think that works really,
really well to communicate
that the entry, the white
background post is a child of
the announcement post.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and the
profile photos are very small
in the current version.
It's definitely something that,
when possible, when you
have imagery, when you have high
resolution photos, things
like that, you should definitely
try to use them as
much as possible.
Give them more space than
you normally may.
So definitely consider using
larger images where possible.
NICK BUTCHER: I think that's
one of my take aways from
Google I/O this year from
Alex Faaborg's talk
on cognitive science.
That you have a special part of
your brain which is great
at parsing photos, pictures of
people, and recognizing them
almost instantaneously per page
rather than having to
scan through and read
names and so on.
So maybe not with a cat photo,
but if this is going to be a
person, then making
the most of those
images is a good thing.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
So let's move on to the next
screen which is the--
Actually, this is just
another example.
As you scroll down, you would
obviously see more items.
And you'd have the overflow,
which would contain my profile
settings, help, about,
the standard stuff
that you'd put there.
NICK BUTCHER: It's worth
recapping here, as well, the
rules we tend to think about for
when things should be in
action, which is immediately
available on the action bar,
or when things should
get demoted.
Take something like my
profile is going
to be uncommon action.
You're not going to be clicking
into that many times.
So that probably should always
go into the action overflow,
similar to how help and settings
and about would
always go in the action overflow
as uncommon actions.
You wouldn't want to promote
this to an action item, even
if there was space on a larger
device, because it's not a
common action.
ROMAN NURIK: Another thing I
wanted to mention is that if
you want to encourage the user
to log in to create an account
for your app, using the overflow
for that is probably
not a good idea.
You're probably not going to get
too much engagement there.
But what you could
do is have like a
butter bar, or something.
Like a dismissible butter bar
show up along the bottom of
the screen that says, hey, if
you log in, you get this and
this value.
You just kind immediately
explain the benefits, rather
than showing an icon always
available on screen.
Just make it contextual.
If you wanted the user to login
or register, make sure
that they see a nice, big
prominent bar that they can
also dismiss if they don't
really want to login.
So let's move on to the next.
Actually, this is the
scroll down version.
Notice that rather than having
this extra arrow here to show
all the listings, we just have
like an all listings item at
the very bottom.
So you'd show maybe three or
four items as kind of a
summary of the post.
And then at the bottom,
you'd touch all
listings to take you there.
So let's look at the drawer.
So you have right now, if you
touch that top left search
icon, you get this, I guess it's
kind of like a navigation
drawer to the left.
It shows you the list of
categories, as well as a list
of recent searches along
with search itself.
So Search is kind part
of this bar.
And it makes sense in terms
of proximity, right?
The search bar is right next
to the recent searches.
However, it's somewhat of an
uncommon place for Search.
Users really expect search
to be in the action bar
immediately available.
Not two touches away, but
immediately one touch away.
And it's not really violating
any strong semantic rules for
the navigation drawer.
There aren't any actions here,
except for search.
But it is kind of pushing
the content over,
pushing the top bar over.
And so, in terms of the
interaction itself, it's not
really violating the guidelines,
but it's not
adhering to the guidelines
that we have set out.
So what we decided to do is see
what this would look like
with a proper new navigation
drawer.
So you have Home at the
top, which is kind of
your stream, per se.
And then each of the
other things are
still represented there.
We also added a couple of things
like section headers to
make sure that it's clear
what you're looking at.
And, yeah, you could
do the same things.
You can dismiss recent
searches.
You can switch between different
categories and
things like that.
But the core point here is
that since the action bar
doesn't slide out of the way,
Search is still accessible.
Search is still an action
that's there
in the action bar.
Because it's globally
relevant, it's not
contextually relevant to the
screen that the navigation
drawer is hiding.
So it's totally fine to leave
that action there when the
navigation drawer is exposed.
OK, let's see.
So what else did we do here?
So once you jump into, once you
actually perform a search.
Let's say you press one of these
categories, or you click
on a recent search, you get
taken to this screen.
Which again, has those
persistent top left and top
right, I guess drawers
available.
And it also lets you sort.
So the issue here is that
there isn't a concept of
really hierarchy.
And you're kind of just at
another flat part of the app.
You're just at another part of
the app that happens to be
search results.
There's no quick way besides
pressing the back
button to get home.
So what we did here was
we actually mirrored
a lot of the things--
we copied a lot of things
from the original
or the current app.
We still have, obviously the
images on the left and the
metadata on the right.
And, obviously, we did some
typographic treatments there.
But we kept the navigation
drawer.
I'll actually talk about
that in a second.
And then we moved the common
actions of things like
filtering and sorting, which
we'll talk about in a second,
into the action bar in
their normal place.
Now, in terms of the navigation
drawer, some folks
may think, oh why isn't there
an Up button here?
And the reason for, and this
is kind of contentious.
You could probably go
either way on it.
My thinking here was that since
these recent searches
are represented in the
navigation drawer--
so they're here, right, pizza
or wearing dresses.
Since they're represented there,
those screens that you
get taken to when you press
those should appear in the
navigation drawer.
Or should have the navigation
drawer affordance.
And this is in accordance
with the guidelines
that we have set out.
So if you touch something in the
navigation drawer and you
get taken to a new screen, that
screen should have access
to the same navigation drawer.
So you could probably
go either way.
And a lot of folks think that
on search screens you should
have an Up button.
And I guess this is just
one way to do it.
And then also you have access
to the refined search.
So if you actually want to
filter further, you could
touch it up there.
And then everything else
on this screen.
Nick, before we move
on, any comments?
NICK BUTCHER: No, just a few
comments on the visual design.
I think you've done a nice job
of tightening up the visual
design on this.
I think, especially treatment of
the images, and having them
basically flush with the side
and the below items works
really, really well.
So basically you're using as
much space as you can to show
rich imagery, which is much
quicker to scan than a textual
description.
So I think that's really, really
nice how you've given
that room to show off.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
OK, so let's look at a
couple details here.
The first is that, if you touch
the recent search, like
wedding dresses, that could
be populated in the top.
So that could effectively
be an editable title.
And if you move on here,
so you'll notice that
sort is a sub menu.
So when you touch the Sort icon,
you get a list of sort
options like relevance, price,
or availability.
These should actually have radio
buttons next to them.
That's a design issue.
Kind of like a bug there.
These should have radio buttons
showing what the
current sort is as well.
And then the most interesting
part of this,
I'd say, is the filtering.
So actually I lied a bit.
When you touch on, let me see
if I can go back here.
When you touch here, you
actually don't get immediately
taken to the results screen.
You get taken to a filter
interstitial first.
So you actually get taken
to, wow, let me see if
I can get to it.
You actually get taken
here first.
So as soon as you touch a
category, you get taken to a
filter screen, which then you
can obviously modify.
And then once you choose the
right filters, you can swipe
over to see the results.
So instead of having another
left pane, what we
decided to do was--
filtering is really
like an action.
It's the act of filtering your
current set of results.
So what we decided to do is move
this over to the right as
a right drawer.
As something that's on the
right-hand side like a filter.
Or you could do something like
layer selection if you're
looking at a map, or something
like that.
So we move the filtering
to the right.
You'll notice that it's
not just a drawer.
It's not just a drawer, it's
actually also available as an
action button.
So if you touch the filter icon
there, it actually should
expand and collapse
the filter pane.
This is very similar to how
Google+ or Google One Today do
notifications.
So the idea here is that
instead of being taken
directly to the search results,
you could actually
take the user to the search
results screen, but
immediately expose the
right-hand filter drawer.
And then once they make the
selections, you could just
swipe it out of the way.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
it's like the idea of changing
the content of the navigation
drawer, I'm not a huge fan of.
It's such an important facility
to be able to
navigate around the
application.
The idea of having these
different modes in which
you're in, that lack of
stability, almost.
I'm not a huge fan of it.
So I think it's much cleaner.
And also the fact
that filtering
tends to be an action.
It's not really navigation.
It's kind of acting upon
the data you've
already navigated to.
It definitely maps to an action,
and therefore, like
the right-hand side of the
action in Androids models, so.
I think this is much better.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
You'll notice here that there's
kind of an Up button
or a Back button inside of
the navigation drawer.
Anytime you see that, definitely
try to avoid that.
The only type of hierarchy you
should have within the drawer
is collapsible sections.
So you can have some kind
of a collapsible
item within the drawer.
But definitely if you have
different entire contexts
within the drawer, that's
something that you
should try to avoid.
I think there may have
been-- no, that's it.
So that was the entire type of
redesign we did for this app.
Now before we move on, I just
want to say, the app itself is
designed very well.
It performs really quickly.
The image loading
is very good.
It's a very, very solid app.
And this is also a beta, so
it's not quite out yet.
It's a great app.
You should definitely
check it out.
But these are some of the ways
in which we improve the
navigation as well as separate
out the concept of navigation
from actions such as filter.
With that should we move on to
design consistency, Nick?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, let's.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
NICK BUTCHER: So this is a topic
that we've been chewing
on for a little while.
And I think it's something that
lot of people struggle
with out there.
And understanding how do you
design with Android, how do
you have that consistent with
the rest of your brand and
applications and so
on out there.
So when we talk about
consistency, there's a few
dimensions we want to really
define and really dig into.
The first one is that
cross platform.
So obviously there's a bunch of
different OS platforms out
there which you, your
application and your service,
whatever it might be, probably
wants to be present on.
So there's got to be an element
of consistency so
users know how to use your
application across these.
The next dimension
we think about is
your branding, really.
So even if you're running on all
these different platforms,
you want to be recognizable as
the same service, and how do
you achieve that?
And the next dimension that you
think about, so when we're
talking specifically about
Android, Android obviously has
its own look and feel, its own
interaction patterns and so
forth, kind of wrapped up in the
Holo design language and
the Android design patterns.
So how do you reconcile being
consistent with that?
So there's a lot of confusion
and choice out there.
So to tackle those, we break
it down into three design
disciplines.
We're going to talk individually
about your
information design, your
interaction design, and your
visual design.
And how to be consistent
with those.
So the first step, the
information design.
Android or the Holographic, the
Holo design, which really
isn't going to dictate to you
or tell you anything here.
There's nothing stopping
you from using the same
information architecture that
you used, say, if you already
have a web property or
a different platform.
This is all down to
your application.
I think this just comes down to
good design, where you want
to sit down and map out what the
base entities are in the
information architecture
of your application.
But Android isn't going to
influence this at all.
So this is all on you.
On [INAUDIBLE] slider map
we've put together here.
ROMAN NURIK: I guess the point
I wanted to make here is that
the information design, or
information architecture,
especially for apps that have an
existing, potentially very
large user base or existing
property on the web or on
other mobile platforms.
You don't want to compromise
your information architecture.
You don't want to have to choose
a completely different
information architecture
just for Android.
So when you look at Android,
don't think of it as designing
a completely separate app.
It's really how do I map
my existing information
architecture, my existing
entities, the objects I deal
with, the sibling relationships
of things.
How do you map those
onto Android?
So it's really, in this case,
with the information
architecture portion of the
design process, you really
have to think about,
how do I best
communicate my existing content?
My current content, and
manifest it in an
Android-friendly way.
NICK BUTCHER: So if you take a
look at the example of Gmail,
for example. a product which
has existed on the web and
elsewhere long before
Android came along.
Android does not dictate
anything at all about this.
Obviously using some Android
interaction patterns and
visual design here, but the
information architecture,
there are basically messages,
conversations,
labels, and so forth.
This is purely dictated by
the product, by Gmail.
So Android has no
bearing here.
ROMAN NURIK: It's very important
to make sure that
when a user comes from the web
to Gmail, not that they
immediately see the
same exact things.
Like you don't want them to see
the exact same visuals.
Maybe not even necessarily the
exact same ordering of
content, but you do generally
want them to immediately
understand where things are and
that all the things that
they expect to be
there are there.
NICK BUTCHER: Right.
So the next slice we're
looking at is
the interaction design.
So here we'd say that it is
actually more important to get
a lot closer to Holo and to the
Android design patterns
than to anything
really bespoke.
The reason being that while
users might know your brand,
and so on, when you're in the
context of the mobile device--
When I'm on my Android phone and
I'm using multiple apps,
it's very important that your
application works the same way
as the rest of those
applications that are going to
be used side by side.
So this is where, I think,
interaction patterns such as
navigation are really,
really critical.
That a user instantly knows how
to use your application.
Some users will have multiple
devices, maybe different OSs.
I might use the website for one
thing and the phone for
something else.
But in our research and
experience, users tend to do a
context switch when they switch
between these devices.
So I don't expect an application
on an Android
phone to function exactly
like the website.
I expect it to function
like an Android app.
And I kind of expect
that to happen.
And one point we wanted to
make is that bespoke
interactions, which keep your
brand defined, that's
absolutely OK.
But if you do have an
interaction which is at odds
with the Android design
patterns, it's working out
where it makes sense to back off
and where it makes sense
to do something more bespoke.
ROMAN NURIK: As an example kind
of outside of the mobile
context, on the web you have the
full breadth of HTML and
CSS and styling and stuff
to communicate
your content, right?
But almost every website,
at the top
left, they have a logo.
Their navigation is either
at the top or
along the left side.
And that's really just something
that's in the
culture and in the core
of the web, right?
So people kind of expect that.
So that's the something where
you want to take your
information architecture,
your content.
You're going to bring it to the
web, but you want to make
that you use interactions
that are well
understood on the web.
And it's the same thing
on Android.
So you really want to make sure
that when you come to a
platform you bring your stuff.
You bring your luggage
and stuff.
But you put it into the right
parts of the house,
effectively.
NICK BUTCHER: Nice
metaphor there.
So a couple examples of this
we're going to take a look at.
So we've gone for things which
is are kind of slightly beyond
the stock arrangement
of components.
So here is an app example from
an app called Grand St. If you
haven't seen it or heard of it,
it's a recent addition to
our beautiful apps collection
on Google Play.
It's a lovely app.
So here they're doing
something quite
custom, in a way.
They're trying to give as much
real estate and space to
imagery and description, in a
very, very beautiful way.
So they're bringing very much
their own personality and
their own information
architecture here.
But they're kind of blending
that with the Android design.
So when it comes to things like
navigation and performing
important actions, here they get
much closer to the action
bar paradigm.
So while it's not a stock
action bar, it's been
customized slightly, it's very,
very important that
users are kind of familiar with
that and can understand
that, oh right, this is how I
navigate hierarchically, or
this how I perform actions.
Or this is where I'll look
for supplemental actions.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
NICK BUTCHER: And the next
example is kind of like the
canonical example of that
marquee of bespoke interaction
is something like Flipboard.
So Flipboard's whole value
proposition is wrapped up in
this magazine which you
can flip around.
So that's also a very custom
interaction for navigation.
Which is fine.
But when it comes to other
things, like performing
actions or hierarchical
navigation, they do get much
closer to the Android design
pattern, so using the action
bar affordances.
I'd love to see them get
slightly closer to a stock
action bar presentation.
But largely they're following
the spirit of, oh, I know
where to look for navigation.
Oh, I know where to look
for actions to perform.
So here, these are good examples
of where they're
doing something custom and
trying to bring their own
personalities, but
marrying them
with the Android patterns.
ROMAN NURIK: So visual design?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so the last
way I wanted to look at
it is looking at the
visual design.
So this is really a mixture of
both your own look and feel
along with the Android
look and feel.
So the idea here is to blend
your brand, your own identity,
with the Android
look and feel.
So one example of this
might be things like
coloring, for example.
While Holo visualize language
talks about stripping back to
the minimum, making content
speak, it's not going to give
you any kind of advice about
what colors or what palette
you use in your application.
This is where you have the
opportunity to bring your own
personality to an Android app
and really make it instantly
recognizable as your product.
So here we have this little tip
that using a single accent
color works really, really
well to bring that.
So if you go on to the next
example, which we've picked,
which is Vine.
Here they're doing that trick,
using that single, strong
accent color.
There's really recognizable
minty green color.
While this is a pretty stock
action bar, it's instantly
recognizable, instantly
branded.
They've done a really nice job
of marrying Android visual
design with their own
branding, their
own look and feel.
ROMAN NURIK: I will say that we
do make some suggestions on
color on the design site,
but they're really just
suggestions.
It's not like every app
must use these colors.
But for smaller UI elements
where you need a special green
or red or something, you
could pick those.
But for the core branding, we
won't tell you Android apps
must have these colors as their
core accent colors.
It's really up to you.
NICK BUTCHER: Right.
And the next example I wanted to
show you is from the Google
Play suite of applications.
So these are some screen shots
taken from a recent show we
did on the Play, Play
Store redesign.
And this is within one
application in the Play Store,
but it shows a very
nice variation.
How you can use things like
customizing the stock
components like the action
bar background.
The selected tab indicator.
The bottom color.
Just by using color here,
you instantly have
this branded feel.
I know when I'm in a
music application.
I know when I've switched to the
movies context or when I'm
in a book context.
And this goes much deeper.
Some of their text boxes are
a hint of the same colors.
And some of the touch feedback
is colored the same way.
So basically they used color
really, really well to get
this strong sense of identity.
So it's using pretty stock
Android components, but
bringing their own brand, their
own identity to it.
So yeah, just as a quick
summary, just to wrap that up.
These are where we feel are
some areas where it's all
about your own information
architecture,
your own object model.
That Holo or Android design
isn't going to inform you.
Interaction design, I would
say, is the other way.
It's very important that a user
knows how to use your app
as soon as they install it or
if they come to it with very
little context.
But the visuals is very much
a marriage between your own
branding and the stock Android
look and feel.
ROMAN NURIK: The last thing I
wanted to point out is just on
the interaction piece.
Some of the examples that we
talked about, Flipboard and
Grand St., Some of the most
obvious interactions on
Android are swiping
and scrolling.
And I'd say that both of those
apps, Flipboard does a little
bit more custom, but Grand
St. especially.
It looks very, very custom, but
as soon as you open up the
app, you start swiping
around, and things
just work as expected.
So rather than doing really
custom gestural stuff to do
basic things like navigate
through content, just rely on
existing features, existing
gestures, like scrolling,
swiping horizontally,
things like that.
And users will almost
instantly know
how to use your app.
On top of, obviously, using the
same navigational model.
Things like the action bar,
upaffordance, spinners, tabs,
things like that.
NICK BUTCHER: Absolutely.
So it's not like an all or
nothing discussion, right?
You can't say, I have to be
consistent with my application
because I'm already on other
platforms and people won't
know how to use my app.
There absolutely are elements
that you should be consistent
to, but there's some elements
which it's really important to
get closer to the Android
patterns.
ROMAN NURIK: I think
that was it.
So with that, thanks everyone
for joining.
I don't know when we'll
have another episode.
Oh actually, wait, there's
one thing that
we forgot to mention.
So we don't have a design news
section today, but one bit of
design news that we did
recently announce, our
beautiful design collection
that Nick alluded to.
It's a set of 11 apps that the
Google Play and actually the
Android Design team thought were
really, really awesome.
So definitely check it
out if you haven't.
I believe it's still available
on your phone if you just open
up the Play store, go to
apps and scroll down
to beautiful design.
You should see it.
But just in case we do
have links available.
So what that, thanks
everybody.
As always, I'm your
host Roman Nurik.
NICK BUTCHER: And bye
from Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: See you guys next
week, or the week after, or
something like that.
NICK BUTCHER: Soon.